in the wake of this month's complex
tragedy in Paris it's important to have
clear calm nuance to media coverage like
that of Fox News's judge Jeanine Pirro
we need to kill them we need to kill
them it's true they say tragedy plus
time equals Fox News but who did she
want to kill no prizes for guessing the
radical Muslim terrorists hell-bent on
killing us
oh the same people we've been droning on
about killing for the last 13 years and
there's only one route that can stop
this war Luton America the Muslims
themselves tell me more
our job is to arm those Muslims to the
teeth give them everything they need to
take out these Islamic fanatics but not
everyone at FoxNews agrees with Jeanine
Pirro namely Jeanine Pirro
you and Hillary arms and trained
terrorists and gave them true
battlefield experience and then you did
a cotton run in Libya and Iraq leaving
our weapons behind you know what Jeanine
Pirro might be right
history shows that this policy hasn't
always been awesome in 79 when the
Americans saw the Soviets invading
Afghanistan the u.s. recruited trained
and armed thousands of Muslims from all
over the world to go to Afghanistan to
fight those dirty red comics this group
of freedom fighters became better known
as the Mujahideen and included the late
and famous aviation expert Osama bin
Laden mm-hmm
force Arab nations to choose there
either with us or there against us well
considering that Isis is a product of
the sectarian division perpetrated by
the u.s. during the occupation of Iraq
what it's against us it's also with us
because they are us we made them oh and
look at them they're also grown up with
their guns and their knives men they
have conquered us through immigration
and no one knows more about Arabs
immigrating to America than Justice
Jeanine Pirro
whiz oh and how am American of Lebanese
descent oh it is time for this to be
over and stop sending American dollars
to any Arab country that does not
support this mission Pakistan at the top
of the list
are we morons yes
you